what's up thinkies we have quite the
week for you we got king of sting
halloween we got two food trucks chuck
liddell corey anderson and then we also
got the mega show calabasas fight
campaign with crystalia brian callan
it's all this week a lot of work it's
fun does it really work it's not it's
fun
let's do it
[Music]
big boy
thick light
better do it big you don't live twice
you don't get a chance to do it again
let me show you what the thick life
feels like
thick like
big nation
thick light
big nation
thick light
[Music]
at a time
[Music]
very very scary right there and we got
old traffic cones construction cone here
we go baby we saw him on the brain last
night practicing getting in character
yeah sending prayers
we got that island boy
aloha
i'm from jamaica
we didn't do nothing we're doing good we
want some pear salad huh slavery
you want to tickle that nickel baby you
want to hold the gold
you want to enjoy the alloy
cause the road through the straw oh [ __ ]
the road to the strap
goes through the rat
i made either a fishing deckhand right
or a lumberjack but i didn't i thought
bringing a filet knife in would be kind
of too much so i just brought my eye out
we have mr marshmallow
from freaking
ghostbusters baby i crowned these yes
i knifey cone
vancouver
november 4th house of comedy come check
me out
feliz huh
shout out to all my island friends out
there
kingston
guatemala
maui
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push weight break chains go hard
in the street has officially taken a
seat to do a little hot wings challenge
this is uh reality eats we just had them
for a food truck with chocolate l
everything was great so
i gave i asked them to give me the
hottest swings they possibly can and the
guy told me that they had these og wings
og spice
uh it's the hottest thing they had it's
has red pepper red chili pepper in it um
so yeah we're gonna see how many of
these i can take down
and how spicy they are
[Music]
i mean if this is what hot ones like i
can [ __ ] do this all day long i mean
come on let me go on that show i'll
[ __ ] take down every wing they got
this is nothing looking back going
forward get up and go for it go hard
like
joy a little bit of work man that don't
scare us that's it
like subscribe if you don't
i'm jamming one of these [ __ ]
down your throat that's a wrap baby
[Music]
uh so tell me a little bit about your
food truck uh how long have you guys
been doing this so we actually started
in the middle of the pandemic uh like
exactly a year ago 23rd of october 2020
was our first day uh so yeah we've just
been serving you know the best pasta
island has to offer uh i'm french my
mom's french as well and uh we come
straight from there you know from france
yeah she moved actually like seven
months ago here and just doing wow you
know you guys are new here huh you and
you and you i've been here for a little
while but like she's brand new here and
like yeah this truck is actually
you know like a mom and son type of
business awesome what's up guys we're
back with another meet on the street
taking a seat uh yesterday we did a hot
ones challenge with the og hot wings
that they had
today we are going to do a lobster
ravioli review from bel pasa food truck
they recommended this as their top dish
uh and now we're just gonna give it a
try
the sauce
i'm giving nine
this lobster in it i probably gave a
seven
and the pasta itself i gave an eight
including the price i'd probably give
bell pasta being a food truck i'd
probably give it an eight and a half
nine overall
it's pretty [ __ ] good
do you want to explain that do you know
how close that is for you bro
so far
yeah but i'll try yeah you're not doing
me a favor by doing it i'll throw you up
dude
how long do you get up there and [ __ ]
around and then i'll come up and i'll
show you how to stop
dude
if i wasn't so hungry i'd laugh at that
we got natural chicken hot sandwiches
for you dude i'm excited where yeah i
brought in a couple of our
hot chicken sandwiches we call them the
nash
like canned bread and made order chicken
homemade coleslaw homemade pickles on
brioche bun um
brought it in for for some of the guys
after the after the companion today
tell me what's their motive i can't let
myself get caught up in their emotions i
just put some ice all on my
[Music]
uh we just watched some fantastic fights
i picked everyone
correctly so i'm very happy with my
fight knowledge truth is i talk to
people who know a lot more about
fighting and then i pretend that i'm the
one who knows and i don't but
who's going to see this right by the way
it was beautiful i had a blast and i
felt like
old times because comedy is actually
about community getting together and
laughing that's why we do it i think for
the most part comedians tend to be very
individual or individualistic which is
to our detriment you know what i'm
saying and the other thing about the
other thing
right right no
no
no no no he's right don't put your hand
down put it in your face like that to
touch it like that he's right no
no no
no look a little worm
yeah dude had a good time with the
fellas you know uh came by
to calabasas it's way too way way too
far but um it's fun i hung out with
these
here at this uh the thick boys studio i
uh
yeah so that's it and uh check out my
[ __ ] [ __ ] these guys check out my [ __ ]
go to my youtube [ __ ]
unsubscribe from them subscribe to me
i'm on crystalia uh and i got videos
coming out crystalia and also more
crystalia and my podcast is called
congratulations
what's up just wrap calabasas fight
companion ufc 276 with chris d'alia
brian callum so much goddamn fun best
time i've had on companion yet
and we have another one coming up
saturday ufc
268 mad square garden the boys will be
back cowbest fight club happen again
next saturday that's a night fight
though not early like this last one all
right but this week i got the ha in la
this thursday friday run my 30 minutes
before i jump on over to dallas texas
where we are there november 11th through
the 13th shooting the 30-minute special
come on out we're gonna add shows in
dallas come get some
until next time thank you guys for
tuning in thanks for watching smash that
subscribe button as the kids say
and if you don't uh if you don't
subscribe to the thick boy channel and
like subscribe every [ __ ] video
i'm gonna haunt your dreams
[Music]